she said to me in the pub so who you
going to have as best man and i sort of
palmed her off and thought oh my mom's
gone blank i just i'll be fine it will
come to me in a moment and i went back
that night and i made a list of my male
friends and i looked down the list and i
realized i worked with most of them and
they'd find it really weird if i asked
them to be best man and the rest of them
i maybe hadn't had any meaningful
contact with them for two three years
and i just thought oh my god where have
all my friends gone
did you watch paddy pimlet's octagon
interview this weekend
i did uh funnily enough i i tweeted
something about that today i thought he
was brilliant and i thought it was
brilliant for two reasons number one the
message which was about friendship and
about guys having to talk about real
stuff to to kind of
intervene in these mental health
challenges that men are having but also
i think the messenger with men is really
important so there's a lot of messengers
that i think men just tune out but an
absolute animal
like faddy the baddie saying this stuff
i think a lot of men are going to buy
into it so i was delighted and i thought
he was brilliant yeah it's uh for the
people that didn't see it paddy is a ufc
fighter currently up and coming people
drawing some
similarities between him and conor
mcgregor quite outspoken he's scouse
which means that he's from liverpool if
you don't know where that is uh very
very strong accent
swears a lot very much a lady lad gets
very fat in between fights and at the
end of this victory that he had uh he
said that his friend had taken his own
life
on
what must have been thursday night and i
think he weighed in
on friday morning so he woke up at 4am
on the morning of his weigh-in so this
is 36 hours before he's about to fight
to find out that one of his own friends
has taken his life and he got the the
text or whatever the alert somehow from
one of the family members
and then used his opportunity to speak
in the octagon about how
men need to speak up uh you know i would
much sooner take a phone call from a
friend that was crying then attend his
funeral he was beautifully done man so
spectacularly done
yeah and in the i watched the post match
he did on espn as well and he went into
a bit more detail he was talking about
how i think this is a scouse word but he
said the thing about women is they can
have a gap he said they can have a gap
with their mates over a cup of tea they
he said they don't stop talking but he
said with blokes
if you try to talk about certain stuff i
think the line he said is like what
you're doing lad grow up and i thought
that was yeah we've all been in
conversations maybe when we were a bit
younger where similar sort of phrase has
been used
and yeah i mean
it's great that someone such profile is
talking about it but in in language that
normal people use you know what i mean
i find it interesting at the moment
because there's sort of two worlds that
are colliding at the same time when it
comes to talking about men and mental
health one of them is
stop being such a victim you know get
hold of your bootstraps pick yourself up
carry the weight you know
re-embrace traditional masculine roles
and archetypes the jocko goggins jordan
peterson style of things but also the
kind of reassuring men you just need to
do some stuff that's going to make you
feel good and reconnect with your
masculine purpose
that is so close to the line of just man
up stopping such a [ __ ] the the next
conversation which is men need to open
up about their emotions men can be sad
too it's important that if you are
feeling down as a guy that you open up
to people and it's not just enough to
treat male depression or sadness in the
same way that female depression gets
treated by making them feel like they
belong they need to feel like they're
worth something they need to feel like
they have purpose and meaning and
capability and those two worlds of men
being told to man up
which has its uses and men are also
being told to open up
yeah that is a really difficult
uh line to pass i think it is i spoke to
a psychologist called fred rabinovitz at
the university of redlands in california
and he's a poker player semi-pro plays
golf as well as running men's groups
being a therapist so he's got both sides
to it right almost like what kind of
what you're explaining and he put it to
me in a way that seems really sort of
simple
which is you need to have a expand your
toolbox so as long as you've got tools
for different conversations that's fine
you don't only have to be one way you
don't have to be new age
mush all the time because i think a lot
of men switch off to that i know i
certainly did
but also
um
there are some times where if you want
to go through the gears in a
conversation to mix my metaphors you do
have to have other tools you know
sometimes in life you've got to have a
conversation about something big and
you've got to show up a bit different to
that than if you're in the pub and
you're having having some fun with your
mates i think it doesn't have to be as
complex as maybe we think it is but i
completely agree with you those two
world views that are kind of rubbing up
against each other but maybe they're
more complimentary than both sides
reckon
i think a lot of it is to do with
expectation because manning up and
opening up it takes a lot of courage and
bravery which are typically masculine
traits in order to open up in any case
but it's more about sort of like
cultural stereotypes what is it what
does it mean to be a man
things like that
going back what got you
starting to think about men's
friendships in the first place
so um just pure necessity i didn't
really realize i had a problem with my
friendships until i was i was planning
on proposing to my girlfriend and i
literally went as far as being in a shop
in hatton garden which is a dueling
jewelers district in london i went with
a female
pal for sort of moral and aesthetic
support because i don't know what i'm
doing obviously
and
afterwards having shot she said to me in
the pub so who you going to have as best
man and i sort of palmed her off and
thought oh my mum's gone blank i just
i'll be fine i'll just it will come to
me in a moment and i went back that
night and i made a list
of my male friends and i looked down the
list and i realized i worked with most
of them and they'd find it really weird
if i asked them to be best man and that
the rest of them i maybe hadn't had any
meaningful contact with them for two
three years and i just thought oh my god
where have all my friends gone and then
i googled the phrase getting married no
best man and there was something like
950 million results and if you click on
them a lot of them are wedding website
forums and blokes saying i'm really
worried i'm getting i'm telling the knot
i've got no one people giving them
terrible advice like why don't you use
your dog
it's awful awful tips
and i realized that a lot of other guys
were in this position and when i looked
into the research i discovered that
men since the 1970s if social scientists
have looked at the data and when they're
measuring this stuff men have had less
friends than women and especially less
close friends and i'm sure we'll get
into what that means to have a close
friend and also what was interesting the
second problem men seem to have is that
this gets worse as they get older so men
have bigger social groups than women in
their mid-20s get to your mid-40s that's
flipped on its head so sociologists call
it network shrinkage very boring term
something pretty simple
our mates seem to disappear whereas
women are better at maintaining and
probably developing new friendships so i
thought that was interesting so why is
that and i tried to work out
the reasons so i could solve my
friendship problem get a best man but
also kind of go this is a quest is
curious right because we're always told
that men have it best but in this case
they don't so what's the reason why yeah
well i mean you know talking about
different inequalities that you've got
in the world there seems to be a
friendship inequality that's going on
here that's pretty stark and
that is upstream from the suicide
inequality that you see as well
yeah absolutely so i mean they're
connected so
uh
if you look at male mental health we as
you say paddy the bad is talking about
it biggest killer of men under the age
of 45
uh certainly in the uk
and the samaritans who look into this
stuff do studies they say one of the
biggest causes of male suicide is a lack
of social support that the fact that men
are isolated don't have people to talk
to there's what's called a big build
effect you know you don't tell anyone
about what you're going through and then
you may be taking action which is
obviously seriously lethal or or
dangerous rather than talking about it
but also physical problems
loneliness is worse for you than smoking
15 cigarettes a day a big matter study
revealed recently
loneliness is worth for you than being
obese or drinking a lot so that's i
never thought that would be true but it
shows you if you get if you get some
mates you can also
abuse your body so there is an upside
buy yourself some beers and some burgers
if you have some mates that that's the
positive but um that's i've read that
that's mad that's because you wouldn't
think it would have anything to do with
your physical body but it does
why is
male loneliness unique then how come
it's gendered in a way
so
it's the way male or loneliness is
gendered is is i suppose two things
one is
that
kind of like i said they lack intimacy
in their friendships so the people that
they can go to and talk about a
meaningful thing so for example the
movember foundation a male mental health
charity recent survey a recent study
said one in three men have no close
friends
and then part of that same study was to
ask that group of men how many people in
your life could you talk to about
something serious like a health problem
work problem relationship problem
50 said no one at all so those sort of
conversations that sort of
sense of someone really knowing you and
you really knowing them men don't seem
to have often that many of those
friendships relationships but also
this was the other gendered thing which
i found most shocking i think is
that when you get to the pinch points in
life so when men get
bereaved so say their partner dies they
get divorced or they retire that's when
they have a lot worse mental and
physical health outcomes than women
because they are isolated and the
grimmest thing i looked at with this was
something known as public health
funerals so public health funerals are
basically when the the council or the
government
uh bury you
because no one's there to do it for you
so maybe you've not got any money but no
one will kind of take on your state and
bury you no one shows up
really sad and this happens all the time
in communities all over the world
america uk
and men were three times more likely to
have those funerals than women even
though women if you look at the stats
are way more likely
to live alone so that's bonkers that's
complete paradox and i think that shows
the level of isolation a lot of men get
to when they do get a bit older so
that's probably the gender that those
are the two things that summarize it
dude that's wild
yeah i couldn't believe it
you said uh the important question is
not whether men are lonely than women
it's how are men lonely and i think that
that kind of reflects what you're
talking about there that it's not just
the breadth of your connections it's not
how many people can you say all right to
in the pub or at the season ticket
seat that you've got at whatever
football team that you support it's to
do with the actual function
of friendships like what why we have
them what they're useful for
and
a million shallow ones does that
compensate for one really good and deep
one
well i mean that's interesting so i mean
i'm sure we'll get on to the work of a
guy called dr robin dunbar later who's
kind of like known as the godfather of
friendship research research
evolutionary anthropologist but one of
the things that he looks at is
introverts versus extroverts so
extroverts have lot a lot more
friendships than introverts but they
tend to be a lot shallower introverts
have less friends but they tend to be
closer so personality type comes into it
and i suppose there's no right answer to
this like loneliness is not an objective
measure it's subjective it's about do
you feel your friendships are sufficient
for you and if you're really happy with
your social life and you've got one
friend good luck to you it doesn't
really matter but i suppose it's where
are you happy with it and i think
blokes if they're honest a lot of the
time it's certainly true for me we don't
like to talk about it i was really
embarrassed to be honest to not have a
best man and it took me a long time to
talk about it and even now it's kind of
like
a bit of a double-edged sword i feel
being the face of billy no mates right i
get introduced on things it's like he's
a guy with no mates and i've done a lot
of work on it but there's a lot of
stigma to it so i think a lot of men
won't confess to it
was it always like this you said since
the 1970s what happened in 1970
i mean i mean this is a really good
question so i mean the honest answer is
they started measuring it so we don't
know what happened pre-1970s
but
so
we can maybe get into maybe why this
happens now so there's essentially three
broad theories maybe the third one you
could argue interact with the other two
the first one and so when i got into
this i thought i go and talk to a load
of psychologists therapists gender
people and go
right what's why is it going wrong for
me why is it going wrong for men and
they would say
the kind of you
you have guests on this podcast before
said the same thing right the man box
idea that we have restrictive gender
norms that stop us having intimacy in
our relationships whether it be i look a
lot at banter in the group so like you
know taking the piss out of each other
that jazz of casual brutality that men
have right which is great fun
but maybe
um
maybe it stops it's a moat around us i
remember i went i forced myself to go to
therapy doing this book and after four
months the therapist stopped and said
the thing is with you max is you can
talk about anything in a funny way or an
intellectual way
but i think your friends get a feeling
that if they go somewhere vulnerable you
won't be able to reciprocate they get an
aura that you're closed that you're not
open maybe that's why you've got no
friends
and after like four months of being with
someone that was like a haymaker that
was like a paddy the baddie
hook to the chin i'm on the canvas going
like okay i can't really deny that so
there's something to it but then on the
flip side we'll get to that later maybe
as well is that you know the banter is a
form of intimacy but it's this idea that
we have these rules another one is
affection
like wait
i i thought when have i ever told a male
friend i like them let alone i love them
i mean maybe after seven or eight beers
and we we maybe won't talk about that so
i often feel like male friendships are
like
a probationary period where you're not
sure you really like each other is there
going to be a job at the end of it so we
kind of keep it at the same level
um
so these sort of basic rules to do with
masculinity you'd say
they're getting in the way the
psychologists would argue but then to go
back to your point chris about you said
about
what happened in the 70s
well one thing that happened in the 70s
is we started talking about gender and
now you cannot argue that it's not
easier to be a man than it was in the
70s in terms of masculine roles it's a
lot looser we can do with much more ways
of being a bloke than my dad has right
who's turning 70 in october but male
friendships the stats show haven't got
better so it can't only be the gender
stuff
which is when you get
into the kind of the second theory
which is
which is
that so you see
we're now coming to dr robin dunbar so
dr robin dunbar who's an amazing guy
he's got a book about friends he's
basically he came up with what's known
as the social brain hypothesis which is
essentially this idea um or he proved it
i think someone else came up with it but
he proved it which is that there's a
cognitive limit to the number of friends
we can have as a human being so this is
150. this is what's become known as
dunbar's number we can only have 150
friends and within that
number there are different circles of
friendship so they go 5 15 50 150. so
you have five really close mates maybe
your parents are in their girlfriend or
a mate and etc etc but he said to me
the the social world of men and women is
really different and it's not trendy to
talk about it but actually if you look
at it it's really different and to
summarize it quickly
it can be represented like this
female friendships tend to be face to
face
based around talk there's a lot of
emotional disclosure male friendships
tend to be side by side based around
sharing space sharing activities often
in groups that's about style and it's
about preference and so fundamentally
there's differences there and that might
be why male friendships
are
less close
and why they may look different in terms
of closeness compared to the female ones
and he also said
that
when it comes to our software so the
stuff in our brain we talked about
something called mentalizing so
mentalizing is essentially the ability
to understand other people's mind states
so with you chris i'm looking at you now
i'm hearing the tone of your voice i'm
reading your body language i'm taking
some contextual clues i'm trying to read
the room and work out what's an
appropriate response here to stay in
rapport to build a relationship
that's all known as mentalizing and if
you they measure that in tasks known as
jack and jill tess i won't go into it
too much but women outperform men what
is it tell us i want to know
so jack and jill tests are essentially
um
they this is how they test i think or
often autism with children where they've
got a jack and jill imagine there's two
dolls it's about
orders of intentionality so it's about
working out so jack think this thinks
this about jill but jill's thinking this
about so and so who's thinking this
about so and so can you follow those
lies of intentionality so for example in
a conversation what would that look like
i say something to you which is a bit
tactless your girlfriend stood next to
you going bloody hell that's a bit much
and her mum's there going god i hate
chris's mates right
okay so that reading those kind of
relationships all at once which when we
see examples like that all the time is
what social socializing is reading the
room reading each other women are much
better at it than men and he said
they're good they're better at it than
men to the factor of they can handle two
more close friends
than women can or the men can i should
say so women can
have two more close friends than women
in that inner circle of five
now that's
there's not much you can do about that
change your gender you can't change the
and that's biologically
hardwired in that's some sort of
predisposition that men have and women
have
yeah i mean we both have the mentalizing
software and that we do it all the time
it's just men are not as good as good as
it i mean the classic example is you
know you go and have uh you go out for
pizza with your mate and then you come
back home and your girlfriend says oh
how so-and-so how's his baby and you go
well i don't know
we talked about
you know we talked about what's how much
broccoli is the in the world to the
nearest square foot we talked about that
for an hour right i talk about baby
but that's kind of in microcosm we see
these things all the time when you kind
of understand the mechanism behind it
you're like oh right that explains it
dunbar did say so i asked him what's the
balance between you know nature and
nurture here and he said that's a 64 000
question we don't know
the exact balance but to say that is all
gender norms and it is all about
psychology
is just not true
did he have a potential explanation for
how this would be adaptive
yeah
so
i i spoke to him and i spoke to another
evolutionary anthropologist called anna
mackin or an evolutionary psychologist i
believe she is she's quite famous she's
got her own stuff out there done a lot
of research with dunbar and it goes back
to
what our french our friendships used to
be for so we can go back to you know
thousands thousands thousands of years
ago
women needed their friends to help them
bring up children so you can imagine
you've got a baby you'd want to really
trust the person you left the baby with
to go to the toilet or to go out the
road to fetch a pail of water whatever
it is you have to really i don't
understand a lot about
primordial men and women but um
you you want to really know them deeply
and vice versa and you want to feel it
was reciprocal whereas the the men would
would have to form uh groups to go and
fight to go and hunt they'd have to have
friendships that were maybe a bit
shallower because you'd be working with
new people all the time you couldn't get
too emotionally attached because they
might die
i mean
that was the adaptive argument right
um and different evolution of
anthropologists have different kind of
versions of that same thing essentially
men have evolved to work incredibly well
in groups and to have those build
builder support within those groups so
status hierarchy is handling that
which is one reason why they argue many
are more aggressive whereas women have
evolved to be they call them dyads
basically pairs have really close bonds
there so that's kind of that's the
argument about where it's come from and
why it's adapted would also potentially
explain why women
use
emotional and social punishment and sort
of backstabby
gossip talk as their form of enforcement
within the group as well
yeah exactly so i've read like a meta
study about aggressiveness and male
aggressive is very out there you know
you punch people you but it's much more
passive like you say we've been much
more around
sort of relational aggression um i've
read a really interesting study by
someone called joyce benninson who's an
evolutionary psychologist from harvard
she's great she's in all sorts of
interesting stuff but she did something
about roommates
so at us colleges male and female
roommates so women share with women men
share with men
but how many of those in second year
chose to live with each other
almost none of the women would live with
each other they'd all go i can't stand
this person
and then the men even though they do
study you know questionnaires going what
don't you or don't do you or don't you
like about this person the member go
like he stinks he's always coming in
drunk his clothes are everywhere he's a
real pain in the ass do you want to live
with him next year yeah why not right
that's so that shows you how like
there's kind of the tolerance there and
i've read a dutch study that that was
kind of about the same thing and the
title of it was i don't like you but who
cares i just thought it's quite an
interesting like study of the male
dynamic
did you did you see i think it was
dunbar that did this i stole this from
rob henderson uh yeah that
women when they're standing talking to
each other will stand
straight on
at whether whatever you want to call it
like 108 degrees or zero degrees or
whatever they're going to be completely
opposite whereas men usually stand at
about 120 degrees and you can do this
the next time that you're looking at a
party or a group of people or even
yourself as a guy or as a girl you can
look at the guys and you'll find that
they sort of just
angled themselves ever so slightly and i
i remembered that study as i was stood
talking to a friend and looked down at
our feet and i swear to god if i'd drawn
a line between them if i'd got my
protractor out i'd have been like
that's 100 that's pretty much bang on
120 degrees and the argument there was
that men when they are face to face with
each other that's typically because
they're ready to fight there's
an increased level of um intimacy and
aggression there uh whereas with women
that that
there's no uh concern
yeah i mean that's i completely buy that
and also i mean when i said face to face
and side by side i mean that's and we're
basically talking about the same thing
there i mean very similar dynamic i
think a lot of people go like might say
well so what of this stuff and i think
it's really important for two reasons
maybe it's the second one in a second
the first one is
that
if you don't accept that men are dif
have a different social style or have
different social preferences you can't
do too much about male loneliness and
male mental health here's two examples
men's groups are really effective for
men maybe more than therapists because
therapists you're face to face a lot of
eye contact really intense chat some
people can do this some people can't
men's groups are in circles your
shoulder to shoulder
and
it's a lot more indirect and i think men
prefer that they they i mean like you
say i mean it might be the angle of the
body the lack of eye contact the lack of
intensity and one of the most successful
interventions in male loneliness in the
whole world is a thing known as men
sheds it came out of australia
and essentially what's happening in
australia is the local government were
putting on all these things like for
lonely old people like coffee mornings
and stuff and men would never show up
and then eventually some baldy aussie
guy went no wonder no one's coming
you know no men don't want to go to a
coffee morning right so he said build a
shed so they put a shed up so men would
show up and build stuff fix stuff
together matt was rammed every week and
they'd come out with friends they would
and they call it health by stealth
because it would the conversation would
come up you talk about your prostate
while you were fixing a pepper grinder
right and it works
and i i maybe it's too phallic the the
pepper grinder and prostate i just i
just really
do it depends if you do that weird
double twisty thing
the girl the girls with experience know
what i'm talking about
um but i went to one and they say
shoulder to shoulder is the key to male
bonding in men's sheds and it's
absolutely you see them and you can't
stop men talking menshets they go they
wang on and people say men don't talk
they do
if you set the context up but you only
set the context up if you don't
treat men like they're exactly the same
as women and that's important what do
you think are the
uh ways in which
men and male mental health is being
treated like female mental health what
what is female mental health and what
are the ways that that tries to be fixed
that have then been ported across onto
men
i think
i think it's how it's
diagnosed i should say i'm not
i'm not mental health professional so
i'm just talking about some of the
research i've read in my own personal
experience
so
there's this theory called tendon
befriend which a lot of psychologists
are
really behind this is not some esoteric
piece of nonsense that i've plucked out
of thin air you can google it there's
lots of evidence for it it's essentially
how the different genders deal with
stress and upset
women
tend to tend and befriend they get
really upset they suffer trauma they
seek people out they want comfort they
want to talk about it men tend to do the
opposite they tend to withdraw
or they tend to act out and they get
they drink a lot they do drugs they
fight so i think often we maybe men
don't understand they're having mental
health problems or we don't understand
men are having it because they're doing
things that don't look like depression
they're not crying they're not on
people's shoulder they're not low energy
they're just not there
like um
my
they won't hear this i can say a friend
of my parents is
like incredibly obese and it's so obese
that he's had his basically most of his
stomach removed
and he lost all his weight and then his
wife has left him and i saw him the
other day and he's put all he's huge
again he's basically eaten through his
stomach
and my parents and their friends were
like oh you know that's classic
so-and-so you know he's a bit of a
character he loves his food i'm like
that's not that's mental illness
that he's depressed he is depressed
and until you see that this guy isn't
going to get any help but it's because
he doesn't look depressed because he's
not doing what we would if you've got
people to write down on a postcard what
is depression they go crying
eyes on the floor you know all kind of
all the body language and the but it's
different for guys and i think it's
important
that we understand that because
otherwise we can't spot it
i had a guy on the show called adam lane
smith who's a psychotherapist working
out of the midwest and he was talking
about how male depression gets treated
like female depression that female
depression is being made to feel like
somebody hears you like you belong like
you're cared for but he had this quote
and he said uh give a man a purpose and
the ability to achieve it and he'll
crawl over broken glass with a smile and
the problem is that when you get men in
and you make them feel seen
and like they're safe and stuff like
that a lot of the time that i i don't
think that that's necessarily what men
want they want somebody that will sit
and listen for sure but
most of the stuff that you've come up
with so far the shallow friendships that
men have that are bonded together over
the top of tasks like it's a they're in
a shed it's literally a workplace
it's a doing thing
it's absolutely a doing thing i mean
that's if it was a sentence it would be
that it's a doing thing and also the men
shed to go back to that and to come
connect it to men needing a purpose what
the men's shed is it doesn't talk about
loneliness on the ticket or what it is
it doesn't talk about health none of
that crap it's come to the shed make
stuff fix stuff be with your mates
but also they're building they're part
of a community they build the shed
together it's like it's it's bootstraps
it's blokes coming together what can we
do and it is that purpose you're part of
something you're not just you're fixing
stuff doing something you are part of
something and that's one reason which
attracts people men need a reason to get
together and it is the pretence of the
shed that solves the problem but you
need men need the pretence you've got to
give them one um but also even if you're
not of that age or you're not depressed
i mean if i ring up a mate and say do
you want to meet up they'll go uh
yeah what why
but if i say do you want to meet up and
watch the football they'll go yeah yeah
watch the football yeah yeah there's a
reason or yeah play poker or whatever it
is
so that there is definitely something to
this stuff and i think the thing i
haven't
connected it with purpose until with
this conversation but i think that is a
big part of it what was the third
potential reason that linked together
the first two
um
so i mentioned i'm going to come to that
i mentioned the second thing that dunbar
said and it was about what maintains
friendships over time and its activities
building the habitats of friendships uh
spaces where friendships happen we have
a lot of those when we're kids when
we're at college if you go to college as
you get a bit older they disappear and
those activities if you want to maintain
friendships you want to build rebuild
them or keep them going those routines
those rituals
but to come back to the thing you just
asked me what do they need they need
time so the third theory is that a big
turning point in the social world of men
and also of women but as i said it's
worse for men is turning thirty
getting into a serious relationship
often get having a family a lot of
people career gets more intense you lose
a lot of time and there's one thing that
friendships need it's time especially if
you're a guy and they're based around
sharing activities because it's not have
a chin wag on the phone
it's get together play a round of golf
it's whatever and that takes more time
and if you think about as the world has
i i would argue the world has got less
friendly to friendship because we've got
a lot of calls in our time there's a
thing uh there's uh you know a lot more
content netflix whatever you want to do
a lot more on social media with
the stats suggest the research just
we're taking that away from our
friendships there's all sorts of ways
the world is less friendly
to
friendship a big one is third spaces so
a third space is
a space that isn't working isn't your
home right there used to be tons of them
when you're you know 50s 60s 70s 80s
whether it's a church it's a gym it's a
coffee shop it's uh uh you know a park
we used to hang out in these places we'd
meet new people there the place where we
could maintain relationships meet new
people they don't exist anymore
they've really kind of gone down the
toilet for
for for in a lot of communities you
either live miles away from you work
you you live miles away from you
socialize i know i don't live in america
but i know in america that's often
you're driving long distances to go and
socialize in places certainly true in
the uk
so that's that's kind of the third
argument the context whether it be
um the places you meet or the amount of
time available it just makes friendships
a lot harder
does that explain why time with friends
peaks at 18 years old that
routineized
thing
yeah i think so i mean that's that's a
really interesting study that i i quote
in the book but i have it in the
endnotes i think the the resource
so i mean so it's time with friends
pixel 18 then it then it's time with
your girlfriend i think takes over or
time at work and then it's time with
your family
yeah so so by the way i should say that
this isn't all bad news so spending a
lot more time
with your spouse or with your family is
something that men wouldn't do
in the 70s 80s but they're kind of
working men's clubs to go to and other
stuff like that
yeah so you could argue that's that is
moving things forward
but um
yeah i think it's definitely connected
connected to that
are there some common elements of
masculinity that you found in terms of
how people perceive men what a man is
what he's supposed to stand for
common elements like
in the way that masculinity shows up
like what if someone was asked what is a
man or what is a masculine man
was there any common elements that you
saw there
yeah i think it's about
a lot of the things we'll be familiar
with it's about winning not showing
weakness not being seen as being
intellectually inferior
um sexually inferior
career inferior strength inferior i
think that's when it's connected to
humor a big thing about masculinity is
men are meant to be funny not all men
are funny but like it'd be you do not
want to be the guy that's known as not
funny like or do you know what i mean
like we really attach a lot of
importance to being humorous so that's a
big thing i think that connects to
friendships and how we do in how we show
up in them
um and i think loyalty is a big thing
but then we can get into this idea maybe
about is
is intimacy between men does is it
simply different so this is maybe the
more provocative question that i kind of
got to
which is i'll keep on being told that
men have a friendship problem they've
got no one to talk to about all this
stuff but then when you actually ask men
define what closeness means tell me what
a close friend is they don't talk about
feelings they talk about other stuff
and they maybe maybe men's friendships
aren't represented in the modern
conversation because we're measuring the
wrong thing how so
well for example um
a lot when you ask uh men about
friendships a lot of them talk about
comfort so that i'm really comfortable
with my friend right we don't talk about
a lot of stuff but i just i know he's
there it's it's not a it's not it's not
complicated it's just we can hang out it
doesn't feel weird
i feel really relaxed around them they
talk a lot in moral terms men about
friendship which is [ __ ] hits the fan i
know my mate's going to be there on my
doorstep someone has a go at me they're
going to be on my side they're super
loyal
this is resilient this friendship so
they talk about it in those terms they
also talk about a lot in terms of
um
like forgiveness and i think this is
connected to like we talked about banter
earlier that what that kind of
taking the piss out of each other this
can endure it's like the power of
forgiveness oh the example i've given
the book is
um
you know those phone ads where they kind
of smash a phone with a hammer they
throw it in the sea they set it on fire
then it's like the phone still works i
think men for a lot of close friends for
men are like i can do that with my mate
metaphorically
and they'll still be my mate and that's
what closeness is and then also shared
adventure used to be a big part of like
the iconography of male friendships you
think about war movies you think about
um
when i looked at the friendships i
really missed in my life it was that
shared adventure that shared sense of
mission purpose kind of locked in that
time of life and we were doing really
difficult things together that we loved
those are what i missed that for me was
close friendship and it was shown in
behavior not in talk it was in what we
did
so do men need intimacy then or do they
need something else is the word intimacy
is an intimate friendship for a man
something that's different to the word
intimate and what we usually think about
that when we think about friendships i
mean that's a great question because i
think the semantics are important here i
think what intimacy means to men is
different and and i think
when we look at close friendships we
need to understand that that is that
exists and we shouldn't ignore it and we
should count it or notice it and not
look down on it but then we men also we
know this from the mental health stats
men do need
more areas
to talk about certain things they don't
need hundreds of people they can do it
to but i think it goes to the tools
thing right the toolbox
have i got enough
people and enough skills or the
vocabulary to have these conversations
when i need them so i actually looked at
i get to at the end of the book going
like when i'm a bit older i'm 34. i'm
having more conversations now with mates
which are about bigger stuff like you
know a mate who had a
you know a nervous breakdown last summer
a mate who's you know lost her
lost a baby those conversations you
don't have in your 20s often because
your life is simpler so you have to have
those chops
but i also really want the friendships
that are like those other like the
shared adventure ones we just mentioned
so i think you need both but you're
right that word intimacy can fall in
both directions i think it gets confused
i think as well the word intimacy and
and thinking about an intimate
friendship i think you mention it in the
show that a lot of guys
are just kind of
keen to not come across as gay that they
just don't want to be seen as gay you
know it's one of the reasons i think why
men standing face to face it's gonna be
it's like what you're gonna kiss me like
how many times would would you may have
said that if you stood a little bit too
close like [ __ ] hell mate i'm not
gonna snog you but and so i do think
that there is a little bit of
yeah i don't know whether it would be
fear of coming across in that way
yeah definitely but i think it also gets
into your bones and then we forget how
it's got in there at my school
everything you did you'd be called a gay
lord whatever it was
like you had
[Laughter]
american listeners i don't know if
you've got gaylord maybe um
[ __ ]
oh god
you're a gay lord short hair you're a
gaylord you speak french what a gay lord
there was a there was a gaylord there's
a story i heard where um some guy
some like kid in school some it was yeah
eight or year nine so they were 12 or 13
years old or something
this kid had come in with new shoes and
one of the days everybody had identified
the fact like oh new shoes he was called
new shoes for the rest of school i mean
everybody had gotten a pair of new shoes
in the period that he was called new
shoes but that was him
[Laughter]
i spoke to a friend who um
he's like
yeah a friend and his dad went to an old
school reunion
and it was all like they were like 65
they're all old school reunion they're
all boys school and the guy walked in
and everyone starts hitting the table
going one word
this guy had a small dick it was known
as worm at school even at 65
200 people screaming worm at him i mean
imagine that i don't and does that
happen at all girl schools i don't know
i don't think it does like men have
these brutal nicknames and that is kind
of like shows the dynamic right yeah
[ __ ] hell but yeah i think the banter
thing is an interesting one because
i i i as i was reading the book and and
thinking about reflecting on male
friendships and the stuff that i've
learned especially this year had a
conversation with nina power about
masculinity had a conversation with
louise perry about the sexual revolution
matt rudd about men's mental health yeah
and
i think
this is not just a men a male problem i
think this is a british problem
i think that there is a an anglicized
problem to this that we're talking about
and i've only been able to notice it
since i've come over to america so the
relationship that i have and this may be
self-selecting because i'm in austin the
sort of people that come to austin are a
very particular type of people blah blah
blah but
since i've been in america
the general culture is much more
uplifting it is a lot more about
celebrating other people's successes
it is
significantly more open and attuned if
you text one of your friends and say
[ __ ] hell man i'm having a i'm having
a bad day it's like look i'll tonight
i'll make what do you want to do what
should we do where do you want to go
let's do something we'll do something
cool
and that
i i
the sense that you have in the uk and
it's difficult if someone isn't from the
uk to kind of highlight it
but there's
it's a kind of a scarcity mindset
it's a bit of a zero-sum game there's
always a bit of piss taking there's a
huge no-no around celebrating your wins
because it's seen as being a bit of a
gobshite or being big-headed or whatever
and
there's just constantly this below the
surface ambient level of
kind of like stress in a way
of of not
not showing off too much that
everybody's on the on the cusp to try
and find some way to take the piss out
of you and i find that when i go back to
the uk that i slip more toward that
style of behavior and yet when i come
out here it's not so i do think that
this is
at least in part something that's played
into by british culture specifically as
well
yeah i think there's a lot to that i
mean
for example one thing i talk about in
the book is that i i'm really
uncomfortable with hugs
i hate it like that kind of repressed
like
absorbed faux homophobia from school
maybe just in case someone sees you
hugging and calls you a gaylord yeah
yeah i'll call myself a gaylord i was
like where's that come from that voice
yeah yeah yeah and um
it's
but then i think that kind of repression
of a of a of emotion if you compare that
to say french guys kiss each other on
the cheek i spoke to an argentinian dude
called fernando de success who said
argentinian men kiss each other all the
time it's very physically tactile he
runs a an agency in the uk called new
show and what they're trying to do is
change how men are represented in
marketing
um so they're trying to re rebrand links
which used to be spray more get more
when i was growing up when i was a boy i
think now it's something else a bit more
inclusive it's called acts in the states
but he did some cross-cultural study
into masculinity and it is different in
different places but what they had in
common was that masculinity was a
was performed right and you perform it
depending on the context so there's
certain things that masculine in some
areas that are different in other areas
but it's the performance i think what i
realized was i didn't think i did
perform my masculinity and i went to a
party with my girlfriend when i was when
i just confessed having this friendship
problem and she saw me with the male
guys and she was like do you realize
what you're like with men you're like
completely different you become this
kind of belligerent
um you know chest is out abrasive loud
slightly cruel but it's all bans
you kind of do that thing and i realized
yeah i do put a performance on and the
masculinity was not just in me it was
between us right so i think it's really
interesting when you when you say you go
to austin
and you become a slightly different
version of chris and you come back to
the uk
you switch into that that mask comes
back on again yeah yeah well i i
realized this looking back at my
very lengthy time as a club promoter in
the uk
and i realized that for a big big chunk
of time what i thought was being a party
lad and the life of the party was
actually me
lubricating my own social anxiety with
alcohol so what i was doing was i was
pretty uncomfortable around other people
for the most part i didn't have a
massive amount of stuff to say to them
and this is something for young people
if you are especially in the uk young
people
spend their time socializing in
nightclubs you go out thursday night
friday night saturday night between the
ages of 20 and 25 that's what you do
that's how you spend your time for the
most part
but
very few people that do that are
actually meant to be there the reason
that you go there is because it's what
everybody else does so it's just this
big mimetic game and i didn't have a
massive amount of stuff to talk to
people about so i remember looking
dude i ran a thousand club nights right
i ran i was the guy on the front door
the one that every single person in the
city knew and i remember standing in
nightclubs and looking at other people
laughing and joking and talking about
stuff or seeming to talk about stuff but
it's a club right so it's super loud and
i always remember thinking
why is it that they've got so much to
talk about when i don't really
know
what what i should be talking about and
what i realized was that they were
talking about may this song's mint isn't
it yeah this song's min isn't it like
and that just wasn't the level that i
was at that wasn't the sort of
conversation that i had when i was in
private
and what i would do is i'd drink that
would
make me into the simulacrum of the
version of people that i thought that
everybody else wanted
and i think that the mask on that you
put on with your friends and all the
rest of it
a big chunk of that is finding people
that you genuinely feel that you can be
yourself around i've got this
go ahead
i got a theory about introversion that
most people aren't introverts they're
just around friends that are [ __ ]
like most people are super extroverted
when they're around people that they
adore having conversations with but if
you're not the difference between being
an introvert and being around people
that you don't have anything to talk to
with
is basically the same thing who wants to
go out of the house if you've got if the
only people that you have to talk to are
ones that you have to be drunk to be
around
absolutely i think
i heard a couple of things i can't
remember who said it but it said your
good friends as someone who make
um your best self
make you feel that your best self is
your true self which i think is lovely
but also
without getting pretentious aristotle
who's like first wrote about friendships
in ancient greece
he basically said what friendship is is
it's a mirror so your great mates are
like a mirror to you and i think that's
almost right
but
who you're with it's not just a plain
mirror because it's shaped in their
shape so they'll reflect back what they
want to reflect back if they're boring
they'll find the bits in you that are
boring if they're bawdy or facile
or
dumb they're gonna find those bits in
you and you when you spend time with
those people you go oh maybe i'm not
interesting maybe i am
this lad because that's what they're
seeing in me and that's what they're
reflecting back to me but it's it's
entirely
to do with the context and you go
somewhere else so actually
i
went off being friends with men because
a lot of my friends was kind of maybe
similar to the vibe you're talking about
in the clubs right were very kind of
archetypically lady bulldee and there's
nothing wrong with that but all the time
and i find when i found when when i was
with women i'd bring out a completely
different side of myself
and i'd be much more complex i'd be much
more fully myself and but discover i had
a much more
interesting varied self and i just
thought maybe it is um
maybe it is a gender thing but but then
like you say if you find the right
friends doesn't matter their gender
then you can you can find something that
isn't a performance i think that the uk
seems to be a lot more memetic generally
so that groups seem to meme each other
more harshly and that that inevitably
ends up shaving off all of the
interesting and odd different edges from
everybody until you kind of have an
archetype of like the lad right the
larry lagerlauty sort of dude that does
the banter thing but i think i genuinely
think it's a case of continuing to lean
into being yourself and unapologetically
as much as possible which is hard if you
don't have positive reinforcement which
is why finding someone that you can even
i remember the first ever guy that i
lived with who
made me feel comfortable around
genuinely having intellectual interests
and i was maybe 23 or 24 and i'd watch
documentaries about
potential solutions to the fermi paradox
and it is the great filter the reason
that we haven't ascended to a type 2
civilization on the kardashev scale and
stuff and but then i'd go to the
nightclubs and be all right mate how are
you mate yeah fine mate whatever like
that would be me who's got the bags so
i would
have almost like a bruce wayne batman
thing like a two lives going on but then
i lived with this guy who
was like that pretty unapologetically
because he didn't have the nightlife
side to him and i thought oh [ __ ] i can
actually be
i can have this curiosity and that can
inhabit the personality that i am
and um
yeah i think it's a case of trying to
find people that permit you to be more
like the self that you want to be and
the more that you lean into that you get
positive reinforcement for being you and
you no longer need to play this role
that's always felt a bit sort of
shallow and pointless and and icky and
sort of and you come home and you never
really feel that good
that was one of the big changes for
myself
yeah absolutely i mean i've written
various bits of press for
newspapers in the uk and then on the
comment section i normally have a look
at the comment section which is always a
mixed bag admittedly
but it's interesting when people come
back and some people
say oh i think friendship's overrated
that all my friends are dicks or and i
just think you've got the wrong friends
correct friendship is massively
massively a creative force get the right
friends it makes you who you are and
makes you a much
better person you find the wrong friends
it shrinks you so
again but then
you get maybe also
the friends you deserve you have to be
invested i think in that journey as well
like you this guy you've mentioned here
gave you permission to be that but he
couldn't give you permission unless you
had that in you and you were showing up
and you had that curiosity yeah the
first mover of where does the uh
authentic self come from is kind of an
interesting one i suppose you know do
people allow you to be more of you how
can you be more of you if you're not
being you at all
but yeah i uh
what you spoke there's this term
emotional labor
what's that yeah
so emotional labor is um
it was a term originally created by
someone called ali horshard who's a
sociologist and it was about work so
emotional labor is the emotional work
that people in the service industry do
to do their jobs so you go to a server
who's having a [ __ ] day that has a huge
grin on her face and she gives you your
latte even though she wants to
stab you in the eyes right or you know
the the person the waitress on the on
the airplane who's handing out nuts and
she's had it up to a up to her teeth
with difficult passengers but is smiling
that's emotional labor but it's then
grown to be this
then it was became this feminist idea
that it's the work women do
to keep people's lives going so it's
they're buying uh their husbands um
uh you know dry cleaning they are uh
fixing you know things in the
supermarket they're going oh on saturday
we're going for dinner with the chiltons
or whatever it is all that work of
remembering and organizing people's
lives so they have a nice time that men
don't notice
and goes unpaid is emotional labour or
mental load but
connected to this in the world of
friendships
and relationships is this idea called
kin keeping which is in
families it's the women who hold the
family together they organize the
celebrations a similar idea to emotional
labor they kind of organize to get
together to keep people up to date with
each other's news on the phone
but then think about it in friendship
groups often
men will outsource that social work
to their wife and girlfriend they treat
the women in their lives like the hr
department but if they were being honest
they'd say you know this is um
jane and the director of people
operations that jeff limited that's for
the conversations they'd have and it was
true in my life i was i basically holded
my girlfriend social group because it
was easy and i couldn't really be
bothered or i wasn't aware of the work
that went into maintaining friendship
groups so like connected to that third
theory about time women have the same
time restrictions generally
yeah they haven't got the same
friendship problem as men so i think
this idea of emotional labor is
massively part of it and is connected to
how we hold relationships together
is there a problem with marriage and
does something happen when men get into
marriages do they either settle in and
believe that this is all i need to
or is there an issue with the disney
vacation of marriage that your wife
should be the only thing that you need
some expectations going on here that
restrict men's ability to have
friendships uh post-marriage yeah
there's that's a massive i think that's
there's a lot in that um
so there's loads of people who have
studied this stuff
um about the the role the way marriage
has changed and meaning it used to be
that we didn't marry for love we would
marry for power or for resources
uh
the idea that we'd marry for love is
actually very modern incarnation didn't
come until about the 1920s so
we've it's a pretty new idea but now it
is the absolute central thing and people
stand up at their weddings get teary and
say i'm marrying my best friend today
and everyone goes how lovely and i
suppose it is nice
but then you maybe have a problem where
if you've got if you're with your best
friend why would you hang out with
anybody else
so i think there is a cultural idea that
your beloved should be everything to you
your emotional home
uh your sexual home your home for fun
and leisure and
as well as the the parent you co-parent
with that's a lot of pressure it also
shrinks your life if you're not careful
but then there's also part of it where
maybe people buy into that and they
don't like their spouse going off and
having other friendships i think there's
a lot to that
as well but we are surrounded by this
cultural idea that we should only want
one massively important relationship and
it should be in a romantic relationship
i
saw another post from rob henderson that
said social networks have a strong
degree of gender homophobially around 70
of women's personal social networks
consist of women and around 70 of men's
social networks consist of men with most
but not all of the cross gender members
being family members over whom we have a
little choice when two researchers asked
a group of american adolescents to list
their close friends from home and school
72 with same sex so i can see here
just a game theoretic issue
if men are worse at making friends
and men have mostly male friends
that just that itself is the reason why
men are struggling to make friends and
hold on to them that's it you don't need
anything else on top of that i mean i've
that's i wish we'd have this
conversation before i published the book
i think that's a good this is a really
interesting it's a really interesting
theory
um
yeah i think
there's there's a lot to it and there's
a lot of stigma
and we are uncomfortable about cross-sex
friendships as well
like i would i live with women for 10
years to two women and everyone was
obsessed with the idea that we were
banging or that if we weren't banging we
had banged or will bang it was like no
it's fine we won't and we haven't it's
all cool but people like no no you'll be
banging i'd imagine like we can't get
our head around it
yeah what was that thing to do with uh
was is there an expectation around best
friends as well obviously you've got
women who have a
a
social circle that's potentially
uh more intimate than guys that have
them distributed out i remember in
school i used to be asked so who's your
best friend as if that was some sort of
an expectation i always used to
feel
the same way as you maybe with the best
man thing oh well what if i don't have
what if they don't feel like i'm their
best friend but i feel like they're mine
is that unrequited best friendness
yeah the hierarchy in friendship is
really awkward but to go back to
something dunbar said he actually looked
at this
women will often report having a best
friend and what's
interesting i think is they'll often
report being more intimate as in you
know closer with their best friend than
they are with their spouse whereas if
you ask if that was not true of almost
no men but men when you ask them about
best friends they'll go well i can't
really name one person but it's kev
steve jono paul
right pretty much name the beatles there
but um you know they'll say it's a great
it's a group right
um and it's more casual but then dunbar
says something interesting to me when i
interviewed him he said because it's
casual when one person drops out of the
group it's like all right cheers and see
it
and then someone else will fill in and
it'll become a different dynamic and
it's like out of sight out of mind not
not in an unpleasant way it's just like
we've got this if you're over there i
don't i'm not going to worry about you
whereas with with women there's much
more
of an effort to maintain that and they'd
really miss that because it's much more
intense
the bonding over doing things makes so
much sense to me as a guy that's run a
lot of different projects done
businesses
the
sort of bond and this may be true for
women as well but the sort of bond that
i have with the guys that i've gone
through fire and brimstone trying to
create a project or be on a sports team
together or do whatever
is
it's beyond friendship you know there's
even an upper bound on how friendly i
can be with my friends that i haven't
had shared suffering through trying to
create something that's worthwhile and
difficult
you can't cheat that either you have to
do it and um
i think this is coming to maybe
like connected to so much of what we
said it's i call it in the book the
vulnerability industrial complex now
where everyone's meant to talk about
their feelings and talk about
be very outward and and very um verbose
with how they relate to somebody else
whereas actually
the the behavior will show you a lot
more and you when you go through some
something with someone they're being
vulnerable because they're taking risks
alongside you
they're they're being sad excited
um angry when you go through that with
someone i mean in com complex
environments or achieving difficult
difficult things
that is a form of vulnerability in
itself that maybe again is not
represented in a lot of conversations
about vulnerability and actually
chris when i looked at all these
friendships
this was
without well i don't want to sound
depressing
but
friendship is such a confluence of
you
the person and the context
and once you leave the context or you
change or they change
sometimes you can never get that back it
lives in that moment in that time and it
is so special and rare and just [ __ ]
amazing i've got a chapter where about a
guy who used to be in a double act with
on the comedy circuit in the uk and we
came from being students to being
professionals and it's like wow what a
journey and then when we stopped
performing
and we tried our own things career-wise
we'd stop being so close and then when
we get back together now
we're mates but
i'm different he's different
that context doesn't exist anymore and
you're like oh wow
um
how do you think how do you think people
should feel about that should men feel
wistful about that should they try and
hold on to it
i don't i've kind of wrestled with that
i think there's it is you should i mean
you will feel wistful about it but in a
sense i suppose
maybe a more positive framing of that is
when you're having it
you should be just reflect and be
grateful of it i think often we don't
realize
the importance of friendship until they
don't they're not around anymore we
don't have it and when i look back i was
obviously obsessed and reflected my
friendships while writing the book i was
like oh man i really miss that but in
the moment i didn't realize how rare it
was to have that or
how rare it was but it also in a
positive way it shows you how
it shows you that i have this line in
the book i shouldn't quote myself sound
like a complete wanker but i say that
friendship is something that grows on
you like a suntan right when you're
doing something else
and c.s lewis is he's he's like an
english writer obviously quite famous
but he wrote a book about
friendship himself and he says
friendship needs to be about something
so like the he says that the opening
lines of friendship is oh you too i
thought it was just me i'm paraphrasing
that but you know that sense of being on
a common journey common mission but
friends look forward they've got a spot
on the horizon they're moving towards
right it's about something and so i it's
kind of the positive thing is
it doesn't happen great friendship when
you're being timid with life it is
connected to attacking life
and it it you have it's a side effect of
doing interesting cool things if you
want to go out and get more friends
i'm not sure that's the best approach go
out and get a life and do do cool stuff
you're into people will be there
alongside you side by side let's [ __ ]
go dude i love that i love that so much
and it is it is there's an action
there's a vector to friendship
especially amongst men you know how are
you
and this person going through something
together and that makes you know look at
me bro signing my way through adaptive
explanations for friendship but
you and the people that you were closest
to would bond together over the shared
challenge of
hunting of collecting food of ensuring
that your tribe doesn't get killed by
another group of people like why do you
think it is that football hooliganism is
just so like look at the way that these
guys they'll take a brick to the face
for each other because they support the
same football team i always think
they're about heist movies you know you
know those classic you know those
classic things you read sometimes it's
like the old gangsters get together at
70 years old they've got enough money
but they're not doing it for the cash
they're mad they're gonna get caught
they're gonna put in prison for the rest
of their life but they're not doing it
for the diamonds they're going get the
boys back together one more job but it's
the stakes i mean this is this is a
thing you don't
this again without being too wistful
like the stakes of it like the hooligans
i wouldn't want to be a hooligan but i
kind of see it's the kind of the risk of
it the stakes of it like replica you
talk about hunting there you know
we screw this up with dead or that's
more sort of warfare but you know we're
out and about if we don't eat we're
gonna die those steaks are connected to
friendship and maybe it's connecting the
thing you had about purpose it's got to
have some some heft to it the problem
that you have with that is that it makes
friendships sound transactional
it makes them sound like friendships of
convenience like the only reason that
you have a sense of belonging or
attachment to somebody else is because
they can do something for you that
they're useful in a way it sounds like
using somebody i think and there is a
romanticization around not just the
disney vacation of relationships but
also the same of friendships too that
people are supposed to be friends purely
because there's kind of this
soul-to-soul bond between you and
somebody else
but it
there are rarely that there is a very
small number of friends that i have held
on to
throughout my entire life
that i've been able to maintain that
deep level of of connection with without
there being something that we're working
toward yeah um so to quote aristotle
again he said there's basically three
sorts of friendship
one is that friends that are useful to
each other so the transactional thing so
maybe we work together so in an office i
think it's slightly different to some of
these bigger kind of journeys we've been
mentioning that second is we're friends
because
um it's pleasurable so like you know i i
think you're a great fan i'm great fun
we have a great time hanging out but the
third one is kind of harder to translate
but it's about
goodness i'm with you because i see
virtue in you and i really appreciate
the virtue so you can be
not nice to be with sometimes or you're
not necessarily useful to me but maybe i
really admire um your courage or i
really admire your wisdom or the fact
that you are kind and that you know we
don't have loads of friends in our life
where we can say i just think this
person is
such a good human being and makes me a
better human being but then those also
endure beyond context so like a lot of
this stuff is like they've worked it out
years ago but maybe like you say we've
narrowed down what we think a friend is
vacation is a nice way of putting it but
again it comes down to celebrating that
that when you've got it be really
grateful for it think about this might
be a more modern way that people put it
that they say i just think that they're
a really good influence on me you know i
like myself when i'm around them
that's that sense that you are a better
version of you or you seeing them things
that you would like to be like
you know the training partner that
always seems to gas you up a little bit
more and you go yeah i want to be around
that guy i don't want to be around the
training partner that's always making me
feel down in the dumps when i went to go
and train with them
yeah absolutely i've got a friend called
philippa who whenever i'm with her if we
go see we're in a room together go to a
party or something i watch her work the
room and i'm like
she's just set in this room on fire
she's amazingly kind of
uh kind outgoing interested
like listening the [ __ ] out of people
i'm like what what what i'm looking like
what a good person so that but that is i
don't work with her i don't see her all
the time
she's not useful to me
well i wouldn't say you're completely
unuseful to me but you know it is it is
exactly that she makes me better but
also i kind of aspire to kind of absorb
her qualities what do you think about
the
modern manosphere do you think that that
is helping men at the moment
so it's an interesting one so
i think
if social media and including manosphere
within that is a bridge into real
connection
as in your meeting and having
experiences together i think it can be
positive
i've i think it is a bit of a symptom of
isolation more broadly that it exists
and you get in those groups
often they get stuck in a vortex and
echo chamber getting more and more
extreme and there is a there is a shared
purpose
in extremity so a lot of these people
are
attached to their often mad ideological
beliefs because they are part of
something and these are boys and men in
their bedrooms who don't have a social
group
but they find it online and to depart
from some of these very eccentric views
is to lose that i think it's intimately
connected to loneliness is it positive i
think it depends on the sort of messages
they're finding there a lot of people
you mentioned jordan peterson earlier i
mean i know you you're friendly with him
i've i've never met uh jordan peterson
but uh if you find some messages for him
and go take responsibility for your life
and find a lot of positivity in that
great if you find some other folks on
that
world who are giving you less positive
messages and maybe entrench you in that
isolation obviously less positive but
there's lots of research that your
online relationships
are not as
effective in terms of your well-being as
face-to-face ones and there's not really
a way around that i'm not saying you
should only have face-to-face
friendships but you do need to get out
the house yeah i i have a
mixed feelings about the manosphere
uh
proto idea that i've got about it is
that this is first wave manosphere work
in the same way as you had first wave
feminism and then each time that it kind
of falls well i actually probably know
it it's second wave manosphere so i'd
have said that the first wave was uh
2006 to 2014
so that would have been your uh the game
neil strauss it would have been tucker
max with i hope there's a beer in hell
it would have been very much around
pick-up artistry and game and negging
and neuro-linguistic programming that
sort of fell away because society
basically decided that that was a bit
much mate and then what came back around
were very similar sort of talking points
but
now under the guise of
red pill black pill alpha beta sigma
mgtow in cells like simping only fans
that was the language that got used and
i think that we're moving toward the
tail end of that now as well because as
soon as any movement can become uh memed
as soon as you can caricature a movement
it's kind of becoming a piss take of
itself and i think that you're seeing a
lot of that
kind of space people are starting to
break off and try and find like holistic
men's work or holistic self-improvement
or organic like they're trying to do
something that that moves it on a little
bit more um but
there's certain elements dudes i had
this lady namakhatson who done some
research into the incel and black pill
forums and she basically said i didn't
know this but that if you're in one of
these um in cell chats that if you were
to say
that you had any positive interaction
with a woman that day that you would be
very seriously ostracized or maybe even
kicked out of the group and i was like
oh like if you if you got a girl's phone
number at starbucks and she was like no
no no like if the starbucks server if
her eyes lingered at you for more than
half a second because what that is
giving to the group is an undue sense of
hope what people are bound together by
there is
we're all in this together this is the
shared purpose and what's called
ascending so ascending up out of the
black pill in cell world to somebody
that may be one of the normies that's
actually able to have sex yeah that that
gives
it creates a delta between where all of
the people in the group are and what
they could be and it's almost like look
if nobody has hope then there's no pain
to feel that delta between what we could
be and what we're not and as you see
other people rise up that creates that
compulsion and that pain in you so what
they're actually optimizing for in these
groups is
for people to never actually tried to
ascend they're never trying to do
anything which would pull them out and
the shared suffering is seen as a badge
of loyalty that's the fealty that's the
flag that you're waving it's so wild
yeah i mean
that's
there's also what's what's interesting
about that is it's so there's so many
instances in history where that is kind
of happened where where groups of people
in difficult circumstances have been
swept up in ideology and and one and and
want to get lost with it i mean
it's um it's it's hard to overcome that
isn't it because it's sort of that
ideological not ideological that sort of
primal urge to have brotherhood or have
connection but then you know that maybe
plays into the dynamics of memes and of
social networks online
and algorithms and things i mean it's
it's potent it's really interesting i'd
be interested to know
what the next step of the manusphere
looks like
to give a positive it's not maybe it's
not out in outmanosphere i've got a bit
in the book
where i spent a day with a guy in
ipswich
who lives with 26 lifestyle sex dolls
and uh they're all around his house
and
you think this guy would be really
really weird but he's got two grown-up
kids he's been married
and he kind of he made me banana bread
when i was there we had a cup of tea i
hope he washed his hands
oh
actually did see it did taste slightly
soapy um and um
yeah and he i said so
talk to me about this and he takes
photos of him he's got his own studio
and that connects him to the dole
community
and they don't like calling them sex
dolls because they think it demeans what
it is they call that is the dole
community and through
his interactions and his work with these
dolls he's made an online community and
actually it's quite tasteful it's not
about sex does he occasionally
use the dolls in that way i'd imagine he
does
good luck to him
but godspeed
but it wasn't about that and actually if
you look into the doll world it's really
interesting i spoke to someone who spoke
to realdoll who make
um sex dolls and they're making the name
skits in my mind now but the the world's
first sex robot
and when they ask customers what do you
want in this they're not talking about
self-lubricating vaginas and gyrating
nipples and all that stuff they're
saying we want it to be able to have
memory for affectionate responses we
want it to be able to have conversations
they're actually wanting it to be about
human connection
and my point with this
is that this stuff that seems a bit
off-putting that seems a bit weird that
seems of guys who have maybe lost the
plot they can use these communities and
as bridges
into something more positive and i think
it's important not to
we have to have a complex and nuanced
look at this stuff as well as
calling out the stuff that's terrible
and the idea of manosphere 3.0
yeah maybe we could be a lot more
positive
in terms of applied stuff then what's
the prescription
uh the prescription i think is three
things
one is
so i asked dr robin dunbar i said if you
give me one piece of advice what would
it be and he said join a club
so there's a lot of homily in gender in
friendships you're mainly friends with
your own sex as you've pointed out
already but we tend to be friends with
people who like us so if you're
struggling with friends join a place
where there's lots of people like you so
if something you're into joining a club
and you'll be in that community in those
self-fulfilling loops um i spoke to
someone at the road the other day
crossfit gym they've made loads of
friends there whatever it is for you
improv theater whatever it is and men
need these
uh activities but i would say as you get
older be intentional you have to do the
work you have to be deliberate with it
do not rely on spontaneity the miracle
of diaries sinking so that's the first
thing the second thing is connected to
this emotional labor point which is
i i spoke to someone with amazing
friendships a guy and i said why what's
going on he said well my mates call me
the sherpa the sherpas in those guys in
nepal who carry everything up the
mountain for the rest of their buddies
and he said
they call me the sherpa because i
organized everything but they said if
you didn't organize everything mark we'd
never meet up and i just thought what a
brilliant simple phrase be the sherpa in
your relationships be the one who texts
be the one who organizes even when it's
hard don't leave it to your girlfriend
don't leave it to the other guys you
just look at each other across the ether
in this holding pattern be the sherpa
and then finally expand your toolbox a
little bit so we're kind of coming back
right to the start here have you got
different ways of showing up in
relationships i think this has been a
great example of it this conversation
some of it has been going asking direct
provocative questions some of it's been
banter some of it's been openness and
vulnerability i mean that's a great
example it's different tools to have
different outcomes are you have you got
enough different ways of showing up and
then the three so those are the three
things but then
if you're gonna have a sentence it would
be show up when you're asked to show up
i'd stop showing up i lost my friends
go first when you're not asked to show
up and finally keep going even when it's
hard because sometimes your mates are
going to be [ __ ] because they're blokes
but
that
in a nutshell is the solution max i love
it man i really appreciate the work that
you've done i think being open and
vulnerable about this sort of stuff is
it is a difficult stage to go in and
that line at the very very beginning you
know the difference between opening up
and manning up that is the one that
everyone's trying to walk so i
appreciate you i really really do people
want to check out the stuff that you do
and follow you online where should they
go
uh maxdickens.com is my website i'm on
twitter at max dickens uh i'm on
instagram as well i don't really use it
very much so maybe find me on twitter
guys amazing yeah say hello dude i
appreciate you thank you
thanks mate
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]